in this colorful sea of trash near
Yemen's Capital Sana
there are vials and bottles of toxic
medical wastes
these are not supposed to be here
officials at Allah azra cane landfill
say untreated Hospital wastes is being
dumped every day posing a danger to the
health of workers and residents
we have no solution but to bury the
medical waste with the garbage this may
cause health issues in the future
chemicals May leak into the groundwater
this is one of the biggest threats to
the environment
officials here say sellers only medical
waste incinerator was bombed in 2015 by
Saudi Coalition airstrikes now there's
nowhere to put the waste
we had a strategic incineration plan to
burn these dangerous medical materials
this was set up and was about to be
inaugurated its equipment was installed
and the building was prepared but the
unjust aggression against our people
targeted the building in al-azara Kane
landfill and completely destroyed it
the World Health Organization says 15 of
all medical wastes is considered
hazardous this includes sharp materials
such as syringes and infectious toxic or
radioactive waste and those containing a
high content of heavy metals create a
hazard if they seep into water resources
after the incinerator was bombed we were
forced to mix medical waste with organic
waste this poses a health risk for
humans for workers and it's also a
threat to groundwater
Waste Management workers say they're
seeking money for a new incineration
plant
but with Yemen facing billions of
dollars in funding shortfall after seven
years of war many worry this issue will
be pushed to the back burner law about a
manly Al Jazeera